welcome to the vlog
[Music]
morning I'm gonna do my is that
compression what's up fam vlogging
walking walking it's a beautiful day on
the soccer field can his shoes on
getting this cleats on I'm gonna try
some trick shots yeah I mean I could do
a little soccer juggling with my feet
the other guys thought I could do it but
we're doing it anyways what have fun the
other guys always make fun of me for
this but I love dude perfect do perfect
if you're listening hit me up I'll put
Mike my number name contact email down
here we'd love to collab with you guys
love dude perfect they just do the
coolest trick shots this is the Bend It
Like Beckham and then they're like yeah
hey I'm gonna try and do what dude
perfect does
[Music]
[Music]
we're gonna try the crossbar challenge
the way this works you got to hit the
crossbar or the goal send me that hard
this is the crossbar challenge damn it
you guys know I like soccer but I I like
I like love soccer
this is the crossbar challenge I play
every single week sometimes twice a week
I was terrible when I was kid I used to
play forward I'm really fast and all I
want to do is score goals and like do
tricky stuff with my feet this is the
crossbar challenge here kit though it's
easier to go girl score goals not girls
but then when I was a freshman in high
school
I broke my leg playing soccer I I got a
through ball and then I was running to
catch it and I collided with the goalie
and boom my leg just snapped this is the
crossbar challenge my tibia snap my
fibula this is the crossbar challenge
[Music]
and it was awful
I mean I was recovering for like over a
year and ever since then I've gone from
forward to defense like I've slowly
moved back along the field and so like
now I really get excited by like
stealing the ball and like making a
really good pass ever since I broke my
leg
no tricky stuff but today maybe I'll try
being a forward you ready to wrap things
up let's wrap things up yeah
this is the 15-mile crossbar challenge
[Music]
[Music]
to make cool trick shot video the other
guys thought I could do it maybe they're
right there's my wife dinosaur steven
has had rights we had a couple drinks
[Music]
[Applause]
I feel like we have to be drunk for
watching it play soccer right let's try
the crossbar challenge one last
this is the crossbar challenge how do
they do that without scraping up their
knees up necks bending it like beckham
yeah we're gonna go kick balls we're
just going to see if net can show us his
little trick i hit the ball right here I
could just go directly into the goal but
I'm not I'm gonna put the ball here
which means if I try and go directly
I'll hit this thing I've got to curve it
up and around do you think I can pull
off this banana kick really quiet why is
that
it's your defender does anyone here
think that I can do it thanks for this
point I've mounted my balls I got my
boxes let's do this
[Music]
how to then how to Bend It Like Beckham
now usually I'm that guy
that's the trashcan but hits me in the
face how to Bend It Like Beckham well it
was spinning run-up
and I got it that time
this is the bending like victim weight
tonight says use this part of your
clutch
thank you guys what are we doing here
with YouTube tutorials they feel like
I'm getting close so whatever happens
I'm gonna put on my Brazil Jersey and
this will be my last try
this is the bending light back up
I said that would be my last shot
but I really want to make this happen
practice is over time for the real thing
time for the real thing time for the
real thing
[Music]
ah I did it oh my god it took me like 50
tries Wow Wow Wow I just I love soccer
so much you guys this parking lot of
mine I'm gonna let it shine this parking
lot of mine I'm gonna lead offense and
I'm proud of that fun to challenge
yourself and try to do something they
didn't think you could do this soccer
field of mine I'm gonna let it shine
look it's Ned
we're here at Nets game and net is
hanging with a sucker Bros over there
it's just stupid sighs yeah
[Music]
[Applause]
those are the world
[Music]
Itzik net over 45 tries to do this and I
was gonna try to do it right on the
first try with us is the wall
[Music]
Congress up down five four three two one
Ned continued on to his scrimmage
against the Thursday team a new Jean and
Keith went back to the normal Sunday
activities which are drink thinking but
remember no alcohol and no golf on the
saga fear order try some trick shots on
your own send them to me I want to see
more cool stuff
I really hope dude perfect emails me
this was a vogue it was a vlog thanks
for watching until next time